I can't believe passion would do
something
Jeremy Passion Lemonade such a good song
I grew up listening to this fool so much
because of him I lost my virginity
because I used to cover his music all
the time I actually met him at a wedding
like meeting him were not equal he's
here oh yeah yeah yeah I don't think you
understand I'm a fan so the way I was
told yeah amen so like dude I [__]
love your stuff bro I'm sure you're not
a virgin
and I can tell like I'm making him
really uncomfortable right because I
can't stop Fanboy meeting this guy yeah
he's The Godfather in a way yeah he is
he really started putting out this image
of like Asian people can sing outside of
what we saw from like William Hung right
just out of respect because I wanted to
let him know like how much I appreciated
him was that no matter what you do from
here or not you've reached a certain
level of respect that people fight their
whole lives for you have Legacy a lot of
like Asian American musicians were
karaoke artists you know Jason chance
Jason I love you you covered